Huh.
Another way to look at a patient is as an organism that develops in which has a
sensitive period early in life where environment has a big impact.
That takes us into the developmental origins of health and disease.
If we look at adaptability on different timescales,
we can see that the homeostatic mechanisms of physiology that are doing things
like controlling our temperature and our sugar content and in our blood,
our operating on periods that are from about a 10000th of a generation up to
about a hundredth of a generation.
If we look at Rio static mechanisms,
which signified changes in set points for homeostatic feedback,
then the Rio static mechanisms are on a slightly longer time scale up to about a
10th of a lifespan.
Developmental plasticity is something that has a timescale that runs from about
a hundredth of a lifespan up to a full lifespan.
Then natural selection,
which is generating adaptation rather than adaptability is something that's
operating on a timescale from about a generation up to hundreds of generations.
Many of the noninfectious diseases,
the chronic diseases originate early in development,
autumn,
autoimmune diseases and eight piece are examples.
If the developing organism does not experience,
that's normal [inaudible] they're evolved interactions with the immune system
don't take place and that leads to an abnormal immune response.
We will expand on this.
That's for cancer.
The somatic mutations that lead to cancer are most influential when they occur
early in development,
when cell division is rapid and when the downstream influence is greatest.
The Metabolic Syndrome,
which we're going to go now go into some detail on basically points out that
condition at birth affects the probability years later of type two diabetes,
obesity,
high blood pressure and cardiovascular disease.
And this can happen even 50 to 60 years after the initial proximate cause has
had its effect.
Okay.
There were two early hypotheses for the metabolic syndrome.
James Neal,
uh,
offered the thrifty genotype hypothesis.
It was based on genetic determinism.
He was trying to explain why diabetes exists at all and his,
he posited that a condition of insulin resistance would have been beneficial if
people had repeatedly been exposed to starvation.
The problem is that famines do not appear to have been frequent hunter hunter
gatherers.
Hunter gatherers are not obese,
but they are very rarely starving.
David Barker,
30 years later offered the thrifty phenotype hypothesis instead of genetic
determinism.
Barker was using developmental determinism.
He tried to explain why the Metabolic Syndrome is more frequent in adults who
are undernourished as fetuses and infants and the idea of the thrifty phenotype
hypothesis is that a developmental switch gets thrown that puts the physiology
of the developing organism into a very thrifty state and insulin resistance
state and that that helps to protect it against a starvation regime.
The problem with that is that predicting the adult environment on the basis of
fetal nourishment might not work.
The correlation between the food environments might not be high enough.
However,
we do have data.
The effects really are real and the most striking data that really focused
people on this problem come from the Dutch hunger winter.
At the end of 1944 the Nazis decided that they were going to starve the Dutch
and this famine lasted from about November of 1944 through into about April of
1945 and there were women in the Netherlands who were pregnant at the time and
they were either at the start of the famine in late pregnancy or in mid
pregnancy or in early pregnancy and the exposure to the famine came basically
right here.
Then the pregnancy's concluded at these dates later on,
so people before and after were unexposed.
The Dutch followed this and these are the characteristics measured in adults
about 50 years later that are broken down by timing of prenatal exposure to the
Dutch famine and you have late gestation,
mid gestation and early gestation in these columns.
It's a large column of numbers and you can study it at your leisure,
but to pick out the main points when that stress occurred mattered and it makes
sense because organ systems are developing at different times in pregnancy.
Those who experienced starvation early in gestation later had cardiovascular
disease in general,
poor health.
Those who experienced in mid gestation later had a higher risk of kidney
disease.
It was associated with diabetes and with lung disease and those who experienced
that in late gestation developed insulin resistance and diabetes later in life.
Now,
similar effects occur under normal conditions.
David Barker looked at data from hospitals in Hertfordshire and he looked at the
relative risk of heart disease is a function of birth weight here on the x axis
and wait at one year over here on the y axis,
it's normalized to a risk of one for people who had mean birth weight and mean
weight at one year.
And what you can see is that the smaller the infant was,
the higher the risk of heart disease and the larger the infant was the lower the
risk of heart disease.
These are quite dramatic differences.
This is one and a half times is probable and this is half is probable of having
heart disease.
Okay.
What are the mechanisms that might mediate such effects?
Well,
they have to be epigenetic.
Uh,
because this is not dependent upon the genotype of the patient is dependent upon
the environmental experience of the patient.
Those mechanisms include DNA methylation.
Individual Nucleotide sequences are specifically then regulated.
The methylation binding proteins are part of that mechanism.
However,
there can also be histone modification which is a broader scale turning on or
turning off of sets of genes mediated by Acetylation,
ubiquitination phosphorylation and methylation.
Also micro RNA and RNA editing can be involved in these epigenetic processes.
We do not yet know which mechanisms are responsible for precisely which of these
reactions.
Now the barker hypothesis has been developed particularly by Peter Gluckman and
his colleagues into the predictive adaptive response hypothesis.
This is a change developmental strategy with a delayed benefit and no obvious
immediate benefit.
We know what occurs in other species.
For example,
altered coat thickness in the meadow.
Vole mothers who are giving birth to offspring that we'll be growing up in cold
weather give birth offspring that already have heavier coat before the weather
gets cold.
So there is an anticipation involved in that.
So we know in principle that can happen.
Now there is a bias in anticipation.
The fitness costs of an error in prediction is not symmetrical.
Predicting a high nutrition environment and ending up in a low nutrition
environment,
we'll have a greater fitness costs then predicting alone nutrition environment
and ending up in a high nutrition environment.
So there's a bias in prediction.
In humans it's more important to avoid the downside than to exploit the upside.
Okay.
No,
an alternative hypothesis that the effect is a byproduct,
not an adaptation.
And that the response is aimed at the immediate survival of infants which
contribute strongly to fitness.
The costs are paid much later in age classes that contribute less to fitness.
So this again is the evolutionary theory of aging and that leaves open the issue
of why the cost must be paid at all.
The natural hypothesis is some kind of constraint,
but if it exists,
it has not yet been located.
So this is an area where we know the effects are real,
the data are there,
and there is an interesting controversy going on in terms of how we explain
them.
So to summarize,
early life events definitely affect late life,
health and disease.
We are beginning to understand how and why these effects evolved,
but the evolutionary issues are not yet settled.
We are beginning to understand the epigenetic mechanisms that might mediate them
and research on the topic is intense.
New results are coming in all the time.